Joseph we're here at the Newport Film
Festival it's an amazing day you're
being honored I mean you're 10 actors to
watch that's an honor what does that
feel like to you I mean you gotta It's
gotta mean something it feels like a
proper honor yeah you know when you look
at some of the people that have been
honored with this before it's it's an
amazing company to be in and you know
we're on a boat isn't that fun we're on
a boat talking on a boat we're going to
be watching you very closely and all the
work you do in the future and I'm glad
we're doing it together hey hey thank
you this year it's my year
I can feel it let's talk the latest
season of stranger things real quick
there was an outpouring of support for
your character talk about what that
means to you real quick ordinary thing I
think to be involved with something
um that has this effect on the Zeitgeist
it's a very rare thing in a career and I
feel very very lucky to be a part of
that and for how gracious people have
been towards Eddie yeah it's great it's
so awesome both Millie Bobby Brown and
my Hawk admitted that they think one of
the original characters maybe should
have been killed off rather than your
character what's your take on this I
mean there's a lot of support for you in
this game oh I don't know I think that I
mean they're spinning so many plates
with how many characters they've got I
think they've really got their work cut
out for them next season
um but I can I think there was the right
way for Eddie to go wow it takes a brave
man to say that I'll take it I'll accept
it if you will tell me this this far in
your career what is the best piece of
advice you've got handling Hollywood
handling the career everything that
comes with it Olivia Coleman the dunk
I'll just dropped that there she told me
to have an extraordinary career it's
good to have a an ordinary home life so
I think kind of keep it keep it normal
at home and then yeah let the madness
happen if it does how's your life at
home is it is it can you keep that can
you keep it separate can you keep a
normal home life are you are you
comfortable there yeah definitely it's
been kind of my anchor throughout this
you know the last few months which have
been amazing but I think kind of having
uh the same place that I lived in has
been helpful and the same friends you
know they give you absolutely they keep
life normal as you said yeah tell me
someone you'd love to collaborate with
whether it be in the near future the
distant future somebody you'd really
love to work with in business I think
Michael sanovski is a brilliant director
he directed pig that Nicholas Cage film
he's someone that I have a lot of
respect for yeah
[Music]